we talked on the show yesterday about
how
the determining factor for censorship is
not
what is said
but who says it
so when i say something about how
hospitalizations are being exaggerated
that's fake news that's misinformation
that's dangerous it's a
threat to the public health we got to
censor the guy but then when the
democrat governor of new york says
exactly the same thing
that's good that's fine because she
she's a democrat she's a prominent
democrat and she's not a mean old
conservative podcaster
there's a complicating factor here
and this complicating factor is
exemplified by dr robert malone dr
robert malone is one of the people who
invented mrna vaccine technology he was
an early pioneer on that technology and
even people who disagree with him give
him a lot of credit for developing the
technology that is now powering most of
the vaccines we see around us for the
coronavirus so robert malone has gone
out and criticized a lot of the public
health response to
covet
notably he's criticized dr fauci whom he
says has no integrity and lies all the
time are cotton and surgical masks
effective at preventing the spread of
omicron
yeah
when the cdc says they are effective in
fact they are
dr malone that's a lie is that not true
yes it's a i mean it's tony uh uh what
can i say tony has no integrity he lies
all the time and i've me and my peers
have have been watching this for decades
we just shrug our shoulders and shake
our heads and say it's fouchy
this is not just some disgruntled
scientist or
public health official uh complaining
about dr fauci this has been said widely
for decades since the aids epidemic that
dr fauci is a bureaucrat he's not a
great scientist he's a bureaucrat the
good scientists stay in the lab the
bureaucrats push paper like dr fauci
that all he really cares about is being
on tv that he jumps the gun that he is
incompetent that he mishandles things i
mean this has gone back decades and
decades
dr malone has been censored he's been
kicked off of twitter
an episode that he did with joe rogan is
being suppressed by big tech
so what this shows you is it's not it's
not just about what is said
because the liberal establishments
totally changed their tune on kovid on
the efficacy of vaccines on the efficacy
of masks it's not just about what is
said and it's not even just about who is
saying it
in the sense that it's not just about
the credentials often what i would hear
when i would
push back against big tech censorship in
the last couple of years is i would hear
well michael you're making a point that
might turn out to be true but you're not
a credentialed scientist you don't have
a degree from some medical school or
some epidemiology program you don't work
at the nih so even if you're saying the
same thing as as someone else you don't
have the right to say because you don't
have the credential but there's nobody
more credentialed than dr robert malone
the guy's got very impressive
scientific degrees he was a fellow at
harvard he helped to develop the vaccine
technology that is at issue right now
but what's the problem the problem is
he's on the wrong side
so it's not just what he's saying
it's not just who he is and his
credentials it's a much more basic
political question
who are his friends who are his enemies
who are his allies what side is he on
he's he is right now
not on the side of biden fauci the nih
the corporations the liberal
establishment he's not on their side
so they're going to shut him up and it
doesn't matter how many degrees he's got
doesn't matter how central his role was
to the development of these vaccines
he's out hey man i'm glad you like that
clip
you know dawg
i appreciated that you watched it if you
want to get more clips i would recommend
you ring that bell subscribe get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe leave a five-story view we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you